(light melodic music)
- [Narrator] In beautiful County Clare
in the verdant southwest of Ireland,
there is a man, a farmer, a local legend,
a man who provides a very special service.
- That woman wants someone
that looks like Donald Trump.
(laughing)
- [Narrator] Like I said, it's special.
- [Announcer] This "Great Big
Story" is inspired by Genesis.
(cheerful melodic music)
- [Narrator] Matchmakers
have been helping couples
in Ireland since ancient times
and this guy is one of the last.
♪ I went into an ale
house I used to frequent ♪
- [Narrator] Today the
matchmaking tradition has evolved,
many matches are made at a
festival in nearby Lisdoonvarna;
every year the festival
attracts thousands of people
and lasts 24 days; Willie is
at the heart of the event,
and to him, human contact is everything.
- Oh!
- Let's do it!
- Let's do it.
- [Narrator] This is
Willie's daughter, Elisha;
she's a matchmaker as well.
♪ No never no more ♪
- That's the "Wild Rover" now.
(cheerful melodic music)